I think he sold it for eighty million
dollars and then he bought it back
[Music]
actually should bring this guy in I have
an investment of a good friend of mine I
called him of them and we became friends
he invested he started a company called
webshots
and that I think he sold it for eighty
million dollars and then he bought it
back yes bring him it he bought it back
for pennies and then sold it again for
twenty or thirty million dollars and
then now has bought it back again and he
was like you guys are you know what
something would be interesting is if you
could be like a graveyard or an
unwinding service Undertaker Undertaker
where you can just buy these dying
things and that exists it's a service to
basically wind down your company you
take a fee and you do the sort of fire
sale and I'm sure there's services out
there like this but somebody could
specialize in tech companies wind down
both you have talent you have hardware
you have you know assets that you're
trying to fire sale off and then you
have all the normal business closing
stuff you got to do so you don't get
like taxes next year because you have to
actually shut down your company
officially and nobody wants to do that
it's not fun and investors want to make
sure that that process is done with no
like funny business so that they like
maximize the value
[Music]
you